[Music]
I am super excited to bring you this
conversation um over the last few years
the great Don Madson she goes by the
minimal mom she's got a an enormous
YouTube show that's just jam-packed with
helpful stuff and you might be asking
yourself why does a guy who pretends
he's a tough guy with a bunch of tattoos
who goes hunting and loves mixed martial
arts why does he hang out and have a
friendship with the minimal
mom a woman who helps women clean their
homes and moms clean their homes and I
guess down dads clean their homes I'll
tell you why because Dawn is a great
human being very very wise not only at
this idea of decluttering and creating
space and freedom in your home but as
you'll see in this conversation um she's
somebody that I call personally because
when I was writing building an unanxious
life I got stuck I was surrounded by so
much stuff and it was one of the first
times in a long time I didn't know what
to do I didn't know who to call I didn't
know where to go so I called my friend
Dawn and in this conversation we talk
about mental health and clutter and
stuff and
identity she's so wise full of so much
wisdom and she's just a great person
like I said so check out this
conversation between me and my great
friend Don Matson the minimal Mom right
here conversations I had with college
students over two decades
and landing on this word Addiction and
so when I think of addiction they've
told us for years it was a moral issue
right if you're addicted to something
it's because you're terrible you're bad
and then it shifted to well it's
actually we got a picture of somebody's
brain and so we found it's an addiction
it's a disease right right
and now the conversation has shifted to
no no no addiction is your body trying
to solve for the madness that it's in
right whether that's old trauma stuff or
whether it is a uh something hard or
tragic or abusive that you're sitting in
the middle of addiction works yeah right
until it doesn't until it kills you yeah
right right and so you and I have talked
offline and I haven't talked about this
very much publicly
but I can be so good about my diet and
so good about exercise and so good about
plugging in with my kids and so good
about like working hard to be a good
husband there is something protective
about the chaos that is all the clutter
in my life and I think I called you
during writing the book when I stumbled
on some literature about anxiety and
clutter being surrounded by stuff yeah
and a brain that's designed for scarcity
has found itself in the 21st century
surrounded by just stuff right all the
time right and
and I don't know what to do and you and
I've talk like I've sit there in my
house surrounded by the stuff and
getting rid of it feels like I'm losing
a part of me right and the definition of
addiction is repeated Behavior despite
increasing mounting negative
consequences right and yeah I can't stop
you know what I mean and so I don't
understand this connection between
clutter and addiction and we we've we've
tossed it off as mental health dis I
don't think that's it I think it's
something ER than that I'm wrapped up in
these things help me please right right
well and we like to call it identity
clutter and so you're absolutely not
alone I think this is something many can
resonate with um for some it's books and
guitars teachers especially they find a
lot of identity in books they're also in
the academic world um craft supplies uh
workout gear hobby
things we're constantly trying to show
the world look this is who I am right
and you've said this before your books
look how smart I am my books say that
right and so what if you take all my
books away and my guitars and my craft
supplies then what's the world going to
think of me and that's not wrong though
right like you talk about this in a
tribe we need to look successful so we
don't get left behind so that's why I
want brand name clothes and a nice
vehicle it it's not wrong that we want
to look successful or we want to look
cool we want to fit in so my body's
doing right by itself it's not wrong
right the problem is for most of us so I
like to talk about this as inventory so
everything in our house is inventory
that we have to manage and for women I
think we have to manage more than men
honestly um and so everything is
inventory and so many of these things
are useful they're helpful they're make
our life easier but it's all inventory
that we have to manage and so we can
have a certain amount of books and
guitars and that's great they're useful
they're helpful you can go down to your
basement hang out and jam until it gets
to the point where it's not and so so
it's kind of like this like you know
scale tips right and you're like no I
don't go down there and feel inspired
and I just want to hang out I feel
stressed because there's way too much
inventory down there and that's where
our friend fumio saki comes in cuz he's
like he he calls it the silent to-do
list and those things are nagging at you
all the time what does that stuff say to
you but that's very similar to a drink
it's fun to have a drink with your
buddies yeah and then the second one
yeah and then
it's when you can't stop fun to order
books on Amazon it is and they show up I
got another one yesterday and like so
I'm off book tour I I like to go down a
rabbit hole with one author and that's
cool except I usually get two books in
and then I quit and I've got seven other
ones and I'm always going to get to them
right yeah another older book of this
one author that I love showed up and it
was sitting on the thing and my wife
puts it out now as this like Shining
Moment Like This this uh Beacon of Shame
just you did this right Y and I I can't
tell you the feeling I got it felt so
good like I got it you know what I mean
yeah cuz it was going to make you
smarter don't open it cuz I got I
already have the reward totally right
right that's that's unhealthy addiction
that's not right that's not whole it's
not good it it would be okay if you went
down to your basement and got rid of
four more books that's it that's it
right yeah but I need those to tell M
okay too and that's just it and and I
think this idea with the silent to-do
list so it's this idea that all of our
stuff is sending us messages read me
play me take care of me organize me
don't let me get wrecked and fum will
even say the longer we've neglected
something the louder the messages get
right what a loser you are because you
have not read me you have not taken care
of me and it really represents these
broken commitments with our self right
lies to yourself totally that's
addiction I said when I bought that book
I was going to read it or at least skim
it right and I have not even done that
and so it all represents these broken
commitments to oursel and what does that
do makes us feel even worse about
ourselves yeah you keep secrets and
that's right
right but what do we do we're still here
with all the books yeah I I I think it's
I just my tendency is to skip over this
part which is the discomfort with yeah
the only path I can see forward for me
is submitting to like I'm powerless here
right it's it's that peral that's that
old 12-step thing like I I Outsource my
identity to books cuz they make me feel
like I'm smart I Outsource my identity
to guitars because they are some magical
link to when I was 18 and I played in
Punk clubs right and I can't let that
guy go yeah I outsourced myself to the
fanciest hunting gear because I've
convinced myself that if it all goes
down I'm all right I'm that right it's
and I can just keep going yeah but I
have to deal with the fact that I
continue I can be proud of myself for
not Outsourcing how I feel to the
internet right I don't people can leave
me in comments that's fine yeah I don't
Outsource myself to my mom and dad or my
in-laws right they don't get a vote
right sure but dude right there's
something so powerful about these things
and I have to sit in that discomfort and
say I do do that right I do let books I
do let guitars and to people listening
your dishes your perfect sets your
furnit your perfectly made bed all the
like the throw pillows right right how
much we Outsource stuff and then that
imaginary conversation MH that's what
when you told me that privately that
melted me like the are you just going to
give up on us remember remember you were
cool you're just not going to read us
you're just going to be stupid forever
right oh you're not going to do the
dishes you're just going to be that kind
of husband that's just how you're going
to be and it never that voices those
voices never stop and I think that's why
then when you look at the research and
it literally says now clutter releases
stress hormones right like you have told
me in the past if your house is very
cluttered you don't feel safe in it your
body cannot fully relax and I think it
is it's because these messages we look
at it we're like it's just stuff it's a
book like it it doesn't talk it doesn't
breathe it does nothing right but but
that's why it's these messages so you
know I know the minimalists they have
their rule like the spontaneous
combustion rule right and I they even
asked you this at one point John if all
of your books spontaneously combusted
how would you feel and you said I would
kind of feel relieved right decisions
made for me that's it yeah yeah there
would be this Terror but also this yeah
but once the dust settled kind of like
oh good I don't have to make that
decision right right and so that's good
though right because you you can
recognize then I don't need all of these
books basically what you're saying is I
would be okay if some of these books go
you don't have to get rid of all of them
but unfortunately they didn't
spontaneously combust and you're still
there with them right so do I do right
right and you've been trying to do this
on your own oh gosh yeah for a long time
we we do right we're like I got myself
into this mess I need to get myself out
and often we're embarrassed by the
Clutter yours is yours is kind of like
sophisticated clutter right books and
guitars like you know but for a lot of
us if I have a full bedroom stacked with
boxes of stuff a basement an attic I
can't even imagine inviting someone into
that with me and I feel like you would
be the first to tell other people call a
friend you're going to give them purpose
right going to feel so special when you
pick up the phone and call them and
invite them over to help you and so what
keeps you from inviting someone into
this with you shame I'm going to use
your own words against you that it's not
I realized it wasn't a character flaw I
just don't have the skills that's it
that's it I'm not broken I'm not an
idiot I'm not a loser I don't know how
to do it right so you've probably heard
of body doubling that right have you
heard of body doubling it's a it's a
great tactic for people with ADHD all it
is is having tell me more right all it
is is having someone come and help you
so I have an appointment Saturday
morning I'm going to have someone who I
trust with this uh they're going to come
over and often what's very helpful is
that you might need to tell the stories
of some of these things you might need
to say oh I remember in grad school when
I got this book or this person came to
speak and I was so enthralled with them
and I wanted to be like them or I love
this thing they said that's always stuck
with me so I feel like I need to keep
the book so I don't forget that or I
don't lose it or you know my goal for
today is to clear off this one shelf and
so you're literally just here to hold me
accountable is that okay to go like do
one shelf today oh yeah yes we often
glamorize like I need to set aside the
whole weekend and I need to get this all
done and that is too overwhelming for
most of us because this is it's a lot of
work I mean you're literally going book
by book and saying do I need this do I
not and you'll say because we're trying
to imagine the future right am I going
to need this book in the in the future
am I going to want to reference it again
am I going to I mean you're awesome at
quoting other people in your books right
and so I love it like how you bring in
just everything and so you might what if
I need it in the future but that's
anxiety right trying to predict what I
am going to need in the future so
there's also a part where we need to
accept that there is risk involved with
this there is some risk and that's a
great if if you can invite someone over
to help you body double again body
doubling is just literally having
someone come over they can do virtually
I mean it's scientifically proven this
works virtually this is why like clean
with me videos are very popular um
because you're literally cleaning
alongside someone else even though it's
virtually I even heard of that it's like
doing aerobics online it's awesome it's
not surprising though right because
we're made for community and we need
people right so um so not surprising so
that's body doubling and you might need
to tell the person okay here's my goal
here's my fear um and you need to tell
me it's okay we don't want to invite
someone over who's like very creative
and like oh you might want to keep that
for some no you're fired like you don't
you don't work for this and so you might
need to tell them like hey I like there
is some risk we don't know for sure if
I'm going to need this in the future so
just remind you if I hold something up
and I'm kind of going back and forth if
I'm going back and forth it's a sign I
don't need it right if it's not a clear
yes it's a no and so that sounds like a
good like Instagram maximum but that's
that's real it is real because we only
use 20% of the stuff in our house as
Americans we only use 20% of the stuff
in our house but we have to acknowledge
and this is where I think sometimes
people people oversimplify it is that
there is risk involved with this so I
grew up on a farm in Minnesota my dad
was phenomenal so when you're on a farm
there are things going wrong every
single day correct all the time and my
dad it was so fun because he would see
each thing that went wrong as a problem
that needed to be solved he didn't get
frustrated he was like hm how are we
going to do this and if his initial fix
where he tried to do didn't work he was
like oh I guess we got to try something
else right and so I grew up in this
environment where it was okay to to make
mistakes it was okay to try and not all
of us grew up in that type of
environment and so eight years ago when
I I have four kids ages four and under
my house is a disaster and I'm like this
sucks like I am not enjoying being a mom
this is not the the picture that I
thought this was going to look like
nothing like it and so I'm looking
around and then I hear this podcast with
Joshua Becker who's a well-known
minimalist and he's like did you know
you don't have to have all this stuff
and I'm like no I didn't I thought this
is what you have when you have four kids
and a house and
and everything and because I'm okay with
taking risks and it's okay if I make a
mistake I could over the course of the
next year get rid of 85% of our stuff
and I could do an experiment and I could
just see what was going to happen and it
turns out that it was one of the best
decisions that I've ever made I do not
miss any of the stuff and so sometimes
we need to borrow that confidence from
others those who have gone before us I
mean look at the minimalist my goodness
they're preaching it from the rooftops
right guys this stuff doesn't fix
anything we look at you know we're
collecting data right like talk I need
data you have not read any of those
books in how many years right and so
sometimes we need facts and we need to
remind ourselves like okay this feels
unsettling because maybe for some of us
we're in an environment even now where
it's not okay to make mistakes and there
is someone in my household and I don't
think you're in that situation but for
others that is going to they are just
ready to point it out if you got rid of
something and now you need it again it's
very unlikely you need it again but in
the off chance they are ready to say see
this cluttering doesn't work see you're
just going to go buy all this stuff
again or you shouldn't have bought it in
the first place and you're right right
it's very complicated I so as you're
talking I keep landing on this one thing
and I I I'm always stunned and it sounds
like what you're telling me
is I have to come to terms with the fact
that I'm not
19 and what I have to do is grieve that
Gap right like I'm not I'm not 19 and
there's not a chance that some band's
going to call me that's that ship has
sailed that doesn't mean I can't play
guitar and that doesn't mean that I
can't jam with my son and my daughter
and have fun yeah but I have to let that
part go and that's hard but again I
think that's where inviting someone else
in it we need to tell our story right we
need a big part of grieving is someone
else witnessing it it's right that's it
you have to you have to say it out loud
and so to invite someone over and to say
hey I got this guitar when I was this
old and when I had this dream and so
this is hard for me to let go like let
them know that here's the other problem
it's I've only recently started like not
just like trying to make enough money to
have groceries and so these things
aren't old relics this is me trying to
recapture this is new money right this
is stuff like I'm using current money to
buy 18-year-old dreams the guitar that
the kid never could afford when I was
playing or the shoes I couldn't have and
I have to let go if I have like one
superpower
when it comes to like writing and
stuffff it am it's a freakish ability to
remember there's one line in this one
book that I read nine years ago and I'll
find it and I have to let that
superpower go cuz there's like there's
this one recipe that one time there's
this one dish that everyone laughs at
when they come over and I think we all
hold on to those that
thing and suddenly that it's not a
superpower it feels like it is but it's
not you know what I mean it's not as
pretend yeah and so that's again where
we can have someone to witness it we go
a little bit at a time so again we're
not going to try and declutter all your
books in in one weekend because what
happens if you will do even if you say
I'm going to do 10 books today is you
start to gain confidence in yourself and
you start to say hey I got rid of those
10 books and I didn't actually miss them
the world didn't no and then I got rid
of 10 more and now there's a hundred
gone and it actually feels better down
here right I feel like I can I can start
to relax a little bit I don't walk in
this room and think oh I need to do this
and I need to organize these and I need
to dust these and I should really should
read that one right and then we realize
like you know the silent to-do list is
quieting down I can start to enjoy this
space how I'd hoped but that's where I
think doing it gradually we gain that
confidence in ourselves so that we do
trust the decisions that we're making uh
one other thing don't start with
identity clutter sentimental stuff the
hardest stuff start in your kitchen see
I think the rest of your house is
probably pretty simplified uh don't
start I mean on the Spectrum like this
is the hardest stuff like you are
working through the hardest stuff right
now so it can be helpful to start in
other areas of your home your kitchen
your clothes stuff that's more easily
replaced well clothes might be she said
this morning there's a stack of t-shirts
and she said hey we've exceeded the
number of hangers she said it's time to
uh um and she goes or you can go buy
more hangers and that's like always sure
like you can go buy more hangers or you
can and dude I'm hoping
go through these shirts it's like I love
that one I can wear that and it's insane
it's not rational right right man all
right so I'm G to take from this two
things and tell me if I'm crazy the
Clutter the
stuff is almost like it it it is it's
the gasl light on the I mean it's the
the engine light on the car it's not the
problem it's this sense that I'm using
other stuff to to feel good about myself
MH that's number one and number
two you weaponized my own words against
me like I can't do this I gotta I got to
say I can't do this by myself and I need
to get somebody else to help me yeah who
will be honest with me which for me is
probably G to be my wife and if I I I
can't think of a greater aphrodesiac in
my home if I was to be like hey would
you sit with me for like four hours help
me get some of this stuff out I can't
even tell you what that would be in our
house you know what I mean um
uh
gosh I just have to I just have to do it
but again small piece that's right you
know 10 bucks I'm just start but tell me
if this fails it feels like it fails and
I feel like I try it but I feel like
it's also like a like a little blankie
that keeps me warm is I'll put stuff in
a box and then I put it in the attic and
say I'm going to I'm going to practice I
think it's got to go yeah I think you
need to just fully get it out of your
house you need to complete it get it out
that's the only way you're actually
going to build trust with yourself
that's it yeah cuz I know it's get out
yeah no safety nets you're right on that
yeah yeah okay well thanks for coming by
and
helping